and the human genome it's about an hour
this is a story about DNA more than
anything else and here is DNA DNA
unraveling from the inside of a human
cell in this little cartoon the
chromosomes contain this huge coiled
length of DNA and the whole point of DNA
is it carries the instructions to make
us coded in his four-letter code these
little pegs chemical pegs distributed
along the strands and it's therefore a
great interest to discover the sequence
of those pegs because just as in the
English language 26 letters code
anything we like so it is with DNA that
four letters code anything evolution has
liked to bring and we're one of the
later products of that evolutionary
process but my own entry is always
describing is it was through Sydney's
worm the the the little nematode worm
that he popularized as a biological
model in the 1960s and which led to all
sorts of interesting deviant creatures
like these for example which my my co
laureate Bob poet's has worked on a lot
these are odd mutants that affect the
the egg-laying organ or vulva of the
nematode went through which the eggs
here inside a laid and for example if
the worm fails to produce a proper
bolvar and can't lay eggs then it's
progeny hatch inside it and devour it
from within rather as in modern families
children can do to their parents of
course and and you can have other
variants of the vulva where you get too
many of them and and this is the sort of
thing which is very intriguing and we
had hundreds of these mutants hundreds
of these genes because people could
biologists could map the genes by
comparing the the rates at which pairs
of mutants were inherited from one
generation to another they were able to
map them out and they knew that we knew
as a community that we
wanted to find the actual physical
embodiment of these genes which are just
segments of that long string 100 million
letters of code that Bob was referring
to and the if the if this gene lay there
for example the could quote the question
was to to try and find another gene now
in the in the 70s when I was working on
the lineage it was the only way of
progressing to find another gene was two
rather laborious Lee work along at the
genome in this fashion segment by
segment picking up one bit and then
another and and it took a long time a
graduate student would take there for
three or four or five years of graduate
work to to to do such a thing and so it
occurred to a number of us in the in the
early 80s that he'd be good idea to
somehow rationalize this situation and
turn the very long intractable DNA
molecule into a map meaning that we
would have a set of segments of the DNA
which will be stored individually cloned
in bacteria in our freezers and which we
would have gone through a simple
procedure using enzymes to characterize
such that we could determine which ones
overlapped and so when we get a pattern
of clones like this and one would then
be able to relate the genes to those and
genes are already known like this one
here would would guide us to the
probable location of an adjacent gene
now the purpose of all this was to was
to speed up really the work of the
biologists who were still mainly the
community were working in this area they
were they were actually finding out how
the worm worked but the two labs that
went into this physical mapping that's
Bob's lab and my lab were working here
but now the key thing to this diagram in
a sense the whole point of it is to is
to point out that without this linkage
the whole thing is purposeless and it's
only because we had this giving and
taking this collaboration
between our two central genomic labs as
they were becoming though we had
scarcely invented the word then I think
we hadn't even and the the much larger
biological community without this link
and without free sharing up and down
that link the the exercise is valueless
and so we learned in a very pragmatic
way the importance of collaboration of
free sharing in this process and when we
went on to take these clones one by one
and to generate now that sequence from
them when that became technically
possible in 90s we knew that we had to
apply the same principle and here are
the some of the players the the key
players as far as I'm concerned in a way
that this is Fred Sanger the man who
invented what is continued to be the
method of determining those base pairs
double Nobel Prize winner for his
technologies first in protein sequencing
and then indeed DNA sequencing his
longtime colleague Alan Coulson who when
Fred retired joined me and then of
course Bob Waterston here in st. Louis
and this is the group that began to
first map and then finally to sequence
the nematode genome so that by 1998 we
actually had most of the hundred million
base pairs of the nematode genome and
this as bob says was the first animal to
be published but meanwhile we got sucked
into a much larger Enterprise involving
many more people to work on the human
genome at which you see the chromosomes
here and this spread human genome is 30
times as complex as the atera 30 times
as large I should say as the nematode
genome but also much more complex it
presents a more daunting task to figure
out but there was a the these are these
are some of the people who did the key
management team that join me at the at
the Sanger Center my own my own lab that
was set up in parallel to comparable
expansion in st. Louis and elsewhere in
the u.s. this is the the early
management team but we were faced by a
rather more daunting problem which was
this race which brought the Human Genome
Project
into great prominence and this is a
representation of that race in which you
see one team which is making money as
fast as possible and another team which
is determining the sequence well this
when was this team was also determining
the sequence in a fashion but they were
not releasing it and this was the
problem that arose in 98 that instead of
this sharing this collaboration which
has proved so effective over many years
we now were faced with a competitor in
the former Celera genomics who wanted
simply to keep a private database and
some ways we're going to move out from
this this little paradigm here to
explore what actually happened and also
to explore why it happened and why we
did what we did this is what happened in
the years 1990 at 99 and 2000 basically
which was a tremendous release of very
crude unfinished sequence which we
called politely the draft and this is
what's represented by the purple line
this is a quantity of the of the of
human Dino genome sequence being
produced now this has values and it was
in fact greatly celebrated but the
reason for this huge outpouring of this
imperfect sequence was to ensure that
the private enterprise could not take
complete control could not simply set up
a database for profit and patent the
genes and as I say well explore more why
we fought so hard against this but on
this diagram I want to just notice
another thing which is that this
competition over the imperfect sequence
made essentially no difference to the
production in the public domain of the
proper sequence the fully joined up
finished sequence shown by this line you
see on its gentle exponent they're just
moving on and it's now moving on here
it's in its final stages and is going to
finish off round about here which is the
actual finished human genome sequence
this one goes higher because it's very
redundant and messy and as more of it
you see it's tailing off as it gets
incorporated into the final project so
this is going very well the the the
situation in fact has been success for
the for the
imperative to release this into the
public domain the method that we used in
the in the public domain looks like this
the the mapping just as we did for the
worm and then a selection of clones and
then d this imperfect sequencing
initially for release at all stages
followed by the production of fully
joined up finished sequence represented
by this line this is what Solera were
doing they were cutting out a couple of
the stages this one is quite a constant
subject of technical debate whether this
was necessary this mapping stage but far
more significant is the fact that the
finishing stage is cut out there was no
finishing no production of perfect
profit per product in the in the
corporation there was however
combination of what they produce with
public data and the data was only
released in a proprietary form it was
never fully released to the public and
so what we have here is some is the is
the conclusion that it's it's worked
that we did in fact get the the data
into the public domain and that's the
story that Georgina and I have told in
our book but now this is what the human
genome actually looks like or a bit of
it it's not very interesting is it and
the what one has to do with that is to
go through quite laborious processes
even to find the genes because whereas
in bacteria here the genes are nice
little coherent entities like this this
is the the bits of information that are
being read out to actually make it the
the human genes are shown in this
cartoon are broken up into pieces that
have to be joined together by missing
out the blue bits and this makes it
computationally very difficult to
interpret but the process is going
forward this is one of the many reasons
why it's important to release the data
because you need both to interpret it
freely using all possible efforts to it
and you also need to release it freely
on browsers like this public one here
now this particular one this is just a
page from the ensembl browser as its
called at cambridge where you can access
all this information anybody can come in
here and look at it click on a
chromosome and find it this particular
one is for mouse actually
there's ones for human of course and and
other animals as well this little
cartoon here just illustrates why it's
so important to compare genomes
you see we learn a great deal by looking
and comparing mice with humans mice and
human are really very similar indeed
they're just slightly different sizes
and basically they're they're mammals
and they develop in the same fashion and
you can see that if you take a piece of
sequence like this this is a
representative this is has more letters
it's to illustrate the idea but you
imagine you take a a piece of code like
this you can't probably see straightaway
anything much in it but if you line it
up with another code and look for the
bits that are the same things suddenly
pop out at you and this is what's
happening when you compare human with
mice humans with mice because you see
what happens during evolution is the
bits that aren't useful get drifted by a
drift apart by mutation but bits that
are useful in a needed for making both
mice and humans are retained and you can
pick them out now what we're really
going to to spend the rest of the time
talking about is is various aspects of
what we're going to do with it and how
that bears then on the this question of
free release and white so immensely
important one reason already the
starting point philosophically is that
this common information the common
thread as we call it in our book is the
common heritage of humanity we both
share our DNA and very large measure
between us we also inherit it from a
single source from the the ancestors of
the human race so this immediately leads
me and most people I think to say well
there should be some equality of
treatment of this material there should
be just as a minimum equal access for
poor as well as rich people but it also
that way which we treated has tremendous
implications for the way in which we
conduct our research and there are two
issues here which which rise to the top
in my mind one is that what we know now
is only a tiny fraction of what we shall
know in a few
and therefore any given human gene will
not only have what we immediately see
now in terms of analysis but there will
be many many more applications many more
understandings and therefore
applications you have to come which of
which we cannot yet conceive and another
applet another issue which and we'll
deal with that but another issue which
we shall deal with is the matter that
science as we've seen in the case of the
genome map but it applies very much as
we move forward in computational biology
examining all these multifarious
sequences is that we need to
redistribute information freely between
us for research to go forward but now to
take on the story from this point for a
while Georgina is going to tell you
about medicine thanks John
now the announcement of the completion
of the sequence of the human genome
although by the way it isn't actually
really complete yet as john showed you
on that slide the final completion will
come next year but the genomes been in
the press a lot and it's generated a
huge amount of excitement and I think
that excitement comes because it really
is going to change all our lives
although perhaps not quite as soon or as
radically as some of us might think from
the kinds of things that you read in the
paper and one thing I think it's
important to make clear because the we
can talk about this more later but the
kinds of questions that we get a lot
when we talk do it to audiences like you
is oh you know people are very concerned
about issues like cloning about the
possibility of using genetic techniques
to produce improved human beings and
what would that mean for the for the
future of humanity I think it's very
important to point out that very few
people are even thinking about though in
those those things the vast majority of
the medical researchers here in st.
Louis back in Cambridge where John works
and everywhere in the world are looking
for cures and treatments for diseases
and trying to understand human biology
and human diseases and that's what I'm
going to focus on now so the medical
advances that are going to come from
this there's a kind of hierarchy of
difficulty people say well when you know
we have cures for cancer when will we
have cures for all these other diseases
and there's going to be it's going to be
a period of time before we start seeing
the real fruits of this research emerge
because what we have now is a foundation
it's the beginning of understanding
exactly how the human body is put
together right down on the level of
individual molecules and that's the
information we're going to be wanting to
use to develop new treatments for
disease so what can we do right away
right away we can do things with
diagnosis we can look if somebody
suffers from something that is a genetic
disease a disease that's caused by a
fault often in just one single gene
these diseases include things like
muscular dystrophy cystic fibrosis
hemophilia and it's now extremely easy
to compare the DNA of a sick person with
the DNA the reference DNA from the the
sequence and find out where the where
the errors are and identify that this
person has a genetic condition and what
can we do with that information well at
the moment in terms of reducing the
burden of disease in the population that
the use that's often made of that
information if it's a disease that is of
something is going to severely
compromise the quality of life or even
be faithful to any child that's born
with that disease is to carry out it to
say that perhaps pregnancies should not
go to determine terminations can be
chosen if that's what parents desire and
they can then try for a child who
hopefully will not have the defective
gene but we're moving on from that now
we're moving on from just being able to
diagnose these rather rare single-gene
diseases and to start thinking about
learning more about the much more common
diseases that are likely to affect very
many of us maybe even all of us things
like diabetes coronary heart disease and
cancer which affect very very large
proportions of the population and which
at the moment are are extremely
difficult to treat effectively and the
reason we're going to be able to do this
is because of the the possibility that
the sequence offers to look at variation
between one person and another it's
obvious just looking around the room
that we're not all ident
but we are all extremely similar similar
our genomes are only one part in a
thousand different from one another
that's all it takes to make us the
individuals that we are and those
differences which seem to occur in in
particular places you know if they could
occur randomly anywhere then we probably
wouldn't work as people you know there
are certain kinds of molecule you've got
to have otherwise you just that you
don't you don't work as a living being
but by looking for those differences we
can begin to understand a little more
about the variation in our
susceptibility to disease why one person
might get cancer under circumstances
circumstances and somebody else not or
why somebody can can you know live on
hamburgers all their life and never
suffering from heart disease and
somebody else who seems to eat quite
well nevertheless goes goes down with
heart disease and in order to find these
these differences there was in some ways
rather remarkable collaboration that
took place a few years ago which
involved both the private sector a
number of companies within the private
sector and a number of the publicly
funded projects and and Bob Waterston's
lab here in st. Louis was very crucially
involved in this and also with funding
from the Wellcome Trust the large
philanthropic organization that funds
Johnson's work and they got together to
decide that they would collect all these
places where we vary in the genome and
make that available for anybody to use
so nobody was going to be making their
own private collection and trying to
exploit that they would just all get
together and get this information out
there pre competitively so everybody
could use this so that use it so this
was another example of the kind of
cooperation and sharing that can really
drive science forward and by doing this
kind of thing as I said we can begin to
match up what we know about lifestyle
influences on disease and what we know
about the genetic influences and this is
this is just an example of a study
that's going on I'm sure there are
similar studies kept happening here in
the US but this is one that's just
started in the UK
and they're going to recruit
half-a-million people aged between 45
and 69 take a blood sample from each of
them to so that they have a nun that
they can do an analysis of their the
variation in their genes but they're
also going to follow them up over a
number of years and look at not only at
the lifestyle factors that that affect
these people what kind of diets they eat
whether they smoke where they live this
kind of thing and then they'll begin to
look at what kind of diseases they fall
sick with so they'll have this massive
Bank of information which they can begin
to to you know use that the
computational techniques that are
available now to get some kind of match
between particular genetic profiles and
susceptibility to disease or how those
profiles link up with something like
smoking or diet or or alcohol for
example and this kind of study as I say
it's going to be going on very widely
with a particular focus on these common
diseases diabetes heart disease and
cancers and it's it's an exercise that
may not necessarily benefit those
individuals particularly but it would be
a fantastic resource for future research
on understanding better why we get sick
with different kinds of disease and
moving on from that what we hope is that
doctors will have available to them
treatments that can be more personalized
to the individual many of the drugs we
use today have been developed in a
slightly hit-and-miss fashion and they
seem to work quite well with some people
are not so well with others and and
doctors really don't have much of an
idea why that might be
but once we understand the molecular
basis of disease better then the
possibility is opened up for tailoring
treatments to suit particular
individuals according to their their
genetic profiles and and here's a little
example of that this is very much in the
experimental stage at the moment but
this is a study that was done recently
of women with breast cancer and down the
side here it's looks exciting each row
in this in this table
it's data from one individual woman with
breast cancer and each column is one
gene that's been looked at from the
tumor that she's had removed and the
colors indicate whether or not the gene
is active so the red ones are active and
the green ones are less active and what
they found is that the women whose who
most active genes are this batch that
cluster up in this corner here are the
least likely to suffer from new caps as
developing from Matt and what are called
metastasis which is clearly the problem
that everybody wants to avoid once
you've been treated for one cancer you
really don't want it coming back so the
women who have this pattern have a lower
risk but the women down here who have
these this set of genes more active have
a higher risk of metastasis and so the
doctor knows the oncologist knows that
he or she has got to get in there with
aggressive chemotherapy to try to
prevent these extra cancers developing
whereas up up here they can take a
slightly less aggressive approach to
treating the disease because the risk is
much lower and as I said I should
emphasize this is very much of an
experimental stage at the moment this is
not something that's being widely used
but it's a sign of the direction in
which we're going towards personalizing
the treatments that we have and the
other thing that that we're hoping this
is going to be able to do is because
again as I've said before we're really
understanding the disease at the level
of individual molecules that where you
find a molecule that's not doing what it
should you can design another molecule a
drug that can go in there and either
stop it doing what it's doing or make it
do something that it should be doing and
isn't and here's an example of some work
from one of John's colleagues in
Cambridge just recently this is just a
very crude schematic of a cell here's
the membrane of the cell here's the
nucleus of the cell and here's the DNA
and this is that what the particular
condition they're looking at here is
skin cancer particularly malignant
melanoma which is the most the most
fatal form of skin cancer causes many
deaths and they've discovered that in
the in these cells there's a whole chain
of different molecules here it doesn't
matter that if you don't know what they
are that but all you need to understand
is this is a signaling pathway and if
all these cells in there all these
proteins in this pathway are doing what
they should do then the cell doesn't
reproduce itself but if something goes
wrong particularly with this one here
this is the one they've been looking at
then it turns on the proliferation of
the cell and it starts to make a tumor
when you know it multiplies and turns
into a tumor when really it shouldn't it
shouldn't be active at that time and
having discovered that this hasn't been
done yet but it should be possible to
try and find some kind of small molecule
some kind of drug that can go in there
and and and make that gene that that
that gene worked the way it should so
that the cells no longer proof liberate
and this kind of approach has already
had some success with another kind of
cancer chronic myeloid leukemia and
there is a drug that's being widely used
now that was actually so successful that
the trials that it went into were
curtailed so that it could be made more
about widely available more quickly I
mean it's not a magic cure for all forms
of cancer but in one or two particular
kinds of cancer it's proved to be almost
magically useful and it's it holds out a
lot of hope that we'll be able to find
many more of these kinds of drugs in the
future and use them to to treat specific
cancers I mean the thing with cancers
that makes it Amin in a way easy I mean
they are hard to treat but in the way
that in potentially they're easy to
treat is that all you're trying to do is
kill the cells it's much more difficult
to make something healthy that's sick
them to kill it and if you can find a
way of killing it in this targeted way
that doesn't do the kind of collateral
damage that met much modern chemotherapy
does then truly then the paper cancer
patients are going to be a great deal
better off and I come at the end to gene
therapy which is it's at the end for a
very good reason because it's going to
take an awful long time to achieve I
think many people when they talk about
the the you know the genetic Bennett
sorry the medical benefits of genome
sequencing in genetics they think the
first thing they think of is gene
therapy but actually gene therapy is
going to be far down the line for the
simple reason that although you know we
have all copies of all our genes or in
every cell in our body
but they're only turned on in particular
places where they're needed and if
you're going to do gene therapy
successfully you've got to turn on
you've got to get a new gene a working
gene into the right cell and get it
properly controlled so that it turns on
and off at the right times and that's a
really hard thing to do there have been
some successes just recently in treating
diseases genetic disease sorry
diseases where the the thing that's
wrong is in a tissue that's relatively
accessible in the most accessible tissue
there is is the blood you can actually
take some out without doing anybody any
damage and you can manipulate those
cells put in a working copy of the gene
and put them back and that approach has
been used to treat a condition called
severe combined immunodeficiency disease
better known as some of the cases that
are famous for they were called the
bubble boys because these kids had to be
kept completely free of infection
because they had no defenses whatsoever
against infection and there had begun to
be a small number of cases of successful
gene therapy against that condition but
other conditions for example cystic
fibrosis gene therapy has been in trials
for a number of years now to try to get
working copies of the genes down into
the lungs where they're needed and that
really hasn't been very successful
because it's a much more inaccessible
location where you need to get the genes
I'm just jumping slightly here to talk
about another issue so it may be i've
just very quickly galloped through what
some of these medical advances might be
and i just wanted to go on to talk a
little bit about how important it is
that we all understand the significance
of these developments the medical
advances are going to be considerable
and something that we should all feel
good about but at the same time there
are going to be more problematic areas
that like for example the privacy issue
if you have a genetic test done
regardless of what it shows should you
be obliged to share that information
with your employer for example or your
insurance company and these are issues
that are being hotly debated at the time
and many of these problems arise because
there is there are huge commercial
pressures that the potential for making
an awful lot of money out of genetic
information is
perceived to be enormous although I
think you know everybody saw what
happened to the Nasdaq a couple of years
ago I think it was grossly overinflated
in the early days and people are
beginning to have a bit of a more
realistic expectation but because there
is this there are these commercial
pressures you begin to get information
coming out that is is not necessarily as
well evaluated as it might be and
certainly we saw and you can read about
in the book that in the course of this
race that John talked about between the
private sector in the public that the
public project information that was
coming out of the private sector was
coming out in the form of press releases
whereas the information that was coming
out of the public sector was coming out
in the form of the the DNA information
that was just going out on the internet
where everybody could look at it and you
need to you needed to have a fairly
sophisticated understanding of what was
going on to be able to interpret those
press releases accurately and that's
this is still happening I mean a recent
instance is the company in Scotland
called ppl therapeutics which is
actually the company that was involved
in developing dolly the cloned sheep
well there was a lot of press coverage
of Dolly the sheep but when Dolly the
sheep came out it was because there had
been a scientific paper in the journal
Nature which had been peer-reviewed and
that you know the science had been
evaluated by by the the community of
peers before it got into the press that
same company has now developed a strain
of pigs who have organs that have been
humanized in some way so that that this
is progress towards developing a pig
that might be used at some time in the
future should society decide it wants to
do this as a source of organs for
transplant for humans because there's
always this chronic shortage of human
organs but that research was announced
through a press release not through a
scientific paper is this the way we want
to go there are many other questions we
need to be asking about the balance
between what is public what is private
and the sort of dangers that the huge
commercial pressures that are coming to
bear on this field
arise and that's where John's going to
take over now thanks Georgina and as we
think about going outside our own cell
artists more globally I think we have to
ask ourselves this question because
remember where we came in is that the
human genome is the common property of
us all and consider this against this
backdrop that the spending available for
healthcare is something like 1,000 times
as much in the richest countries of the
world compared with the poorest and that
means that leaving the way we develop
and make available these products these
beneficial products to people is not
going to work very well if we leave it
to the marketplace and we're going to go
through now there's very few specific
examples of how things can go wrong the
way patenting works for example now this
is a complicated slide but I just it's
about the the solution in Iran to to
deal with the increasing numbers of
children who thanks to modern medicine
are able are being born and surviving
even though they aren't able to produce
the the beta-globin it's required for
the transport of oxygen in the blood you
have to transfuse them he laid out the
excess iron which is produced in the
body and is otherwise bad and kills you
and it can be done genetically because
we have the ability to detect these
children and through the issuing of a
special fatwa which allows Muslims then
to to abort these children if they so
wish but the key points are down here
that the cost of this procedure is low
because the local labor is being used
and there is no gene license which is
putting a sort of Western determined fee
on this compare it with this situation
in this case we have the two BRCA genes
which were discovered again this is now
moving into the genomic era and they
were discovered with with a lot of
goodwill from families who put their
genetic data in but the corporation
myriad genetics has now taken control
sufficient control of patents in the US
that they are able to shut down other US
laboratories so testing only takes place
through these to their own labs and so
any American woman who needs to be
tested because she has a history of
breast cancer the point about these
genes is that certain mutations do
confer highly increase susceptibility to
breast cancer if she wishes to have a
test in this country she has to pay
$2,500 or her insurance company does
this immediately excludes a considerable
proportion of women from such testing
and the company is now tried to extend
that control into Canada and Europe and
the court battles are beginning about it
but think about the other countries
where we're not talking about you know
two thousand five hundred dollars but
the more near equivalent of two million
dollars in local terms per test they
obviously cannot have it what's
happening is this that the existing
patent law which very reasonably allows
people who are doing a particular test
to to prohibit others from doing that
and to establish a licensing gate on
that pathway so that others can't simply
do it are not only doing that but
they're also through the the way
patterns are written at the moment are
able to extend that control not only to
all other forms of diagnosis but to all
possible future applications of that
gene including possible therapies
including possible new alternative
applications of the gene in the future
you have to ask yourself I think whether
this kind of broad patenting is
appropriate it is beginning to be rolled
back a bit but at the moment you can
still write a patent in such broad
speculative terms as to give you that
control but there are more extreme cases
look at ccr5 didn't its case Human
Genome Sciences tagged that means to say
just got a little bit of sequence from a
whole lot of of genes that were known to
be receptors they were known to sit on
the outside of cells like the ones that
Georgina showed you in a previous slide
they had a lot of patents floating
around and then when other labs found
that this particular example
phonetically
was a receptor for HIV and therefore
important in thinking about how to
combat AIDS they were able to update
their their provisional patterns and
gain control of the situation in this
fashion by just knowing a little tiny
bit about the gene they were once again
able to extend their pattern broadly now
this in this particular case it's so
extreme that it's quite widely perceived
as being inappropriate and the I think
that they may not hold it but the
trouble is that at the moment these
things are going through at least in a
way that allows those holding broad
patterns to bluff others into not
pursuing the lines of either competitive
or more futuristic research which ought
to be available we're not applying our
minds to the problems because of this
lack of competition and above all we are
denying the proceeds the beneficial
health proceeds to less developed
countries to less rich people there are
other ways and this comes back to the
situation we had with the human genome
in which even without patents you can
take control of a situation should you
be able to establish a comparable
monopoly so thinking thinking about the
whole human genome again since that was
our starting example imagine that you
have the whole human genome it's in the
database and you've managed to stop
other people from producing it then what
do you do with that well what you do in
order to have a viable business plan is
to sell access to your database to
researchers with money like this one and
this one but you do two things you
prohibit those researchers from
communicating with anybody other than
your own database they may not
communicate with each other and secondly
they may certainly not communicate with
others outside the system because if you
allowed them to do that you would
quickly lose the unique knowledge
because you're the knowledge about your
database will be spread all over the
country and nobody would have to buy
into it anymore so your business plan
would fall over so that's what a
proprietary database looks like now what
we've achieved in the human genome is
like this now that looks much more like
a viable pattern for future research and
getting things done in a hurry in a way
which is going to be
truly effective for this unique body of
knowledge there is no restriction on who
may access there's no restriction on the
way they may communicate although of
course downstream they may take licenses
may patent inventions and make profit
out of those inventions in ways that do
not interfere with the common good the
central repository at being available to
all even if we achieve that though as
our researcher at Oxford University
Shiva has pointed out to me in a small
paper about this she says well you know
maybe you guys didn't do such a great
job in releasing all the data because
look what's happening most of the
accesses and we're taking as our example
at the ensembl database again this same
thing we true of other browsers most of
the accesses come from countries like
the US and the UK and other European
countries that have very active
bioinformatics gene ohmic structures and
they under the present system are able
to accumulate patent rights at a great
rate so if we allow this patenting to go
forward this fencing off of sections of
the genome others who at present are
less wealthy miss out and are not able
to participate in the in the fruits so
we have to again make sure that these
later stages are conducting equitably we
cannot do it through companies because
or not purely through companies because
they inevitably will sell to the rich
markets that's their job a company is
there to make money I think it's quite
interesting to look at the balance sheet
of a of a large pharmaceutical today
like Pfizer or GSK they a third of their
budget goes to profit well that's the
sign of a successful company fair enough
just 15% of the budget goes on R&D and a
comparable amount on production but a
thing which I think is very interesting
and the mark of a rather particular kind
of company is that taking advertising
and other sorts of marketing like
sponsorship into account a full third of
the budget goes in the marketing process
but what that means is or what does
think about what it means you know
if an organization has to spend
one-third of its budget on marketing I
think there's a slight suspicion that
they might be trying to sell something
that nobody really wants at least some
of the time and I think that's true
although I were obviously there are many
valuable products coming out of the big
pharmaceuticals the truth is that they
get a major part of their profit from
competing in markets to over prescribe
such things as antidepressants which are
greatly overused in our society and and
certainly we don't want large amounts of
competition between competing versions
which don't have much to choose between
them so the point about this slide is
not to be rude to anybody but simply to
point out that it is not a way forward
to deal with the neglected diseases but
it's actually a little bit worse than
that in a way because the unfair trading
rules that affect a set up and the
European European arif barriers to to
imports from developing countries are
meaning again that the inequality in the
world not just in the health region but
in other ways of moving forward or being
maintained and I think we have to accept
both as scientists and all concerned
citizens that the world trade
organization needs to be encouraged much
more strongly to deal with some of these
situations some of these applying
particularly to our own applications in
biology we've spoken and I've spoken
about the narrower patents needed ways
of dealing with that in the future might
be to pool patents in some way need to
reduce tariff barriers we need to make
sure that developing countries who are
less able to compete with their own
resources because they don't have access
to trained legal teams are in fact able
to take benefits of the set of these
safeguards like compulsory licensing in
the case of drugs which are needed for
urgent matters of health care as in
combating severe academics and we need
to move forward to overcome the lack of
financial incentives we need to move
forward in the research and treatment of
neglected diseases by de stablishing
global funds and that also is is
beginning
- go ahead the point is not that this
situation is bleak and we need a u-turn
but that we need more of these all these
things which already taking place as as
listed on here but the what I want to do
in closing is to thank the all the
members of our consortium who've made it
possible for us to get the human genome
out in the public and to come and talk
to you here about a few of the
consequences and I would like to move on
as quickly as possible to hear what you
have to say because what this whole
situates all understanding is about is
not about preaching but about dialogue
so please come for it with comments and
questions thank you
okay does this one store yeah this is
artillery can uses right yes it does if
I take this house to where in for six
yes
okay so we have time for questions can
you hear is this on you need to get know
if you like it if I get real close so
uncle oh I can look at your eyes I got
these things so you should I usually do
this so there are two microphones for
people to ask questions with and are you
if you just raise your hand our runners
will come and bring the microphone to
you so that everyone can hear it
so please go ahead and ask questions
I'd like to know how the Patent Office
has the qualifications to grant these
patents it seems like to me that it's
such a complex topic that the expertise
might be questionable Jim Taylor I can
run well I mean I think there it clearly
patent law in the area of biomedicine is
a specialized area that has a number of
experts in it but really it's a question
of how widely they've been allowed to
set their rules and patent offices both
here in the US and in Europe have in
their wisdom there's somewhat doubtful
wisdom we would argue seem to invent
their own rules because there is there
supposed to be there's absolutely clear
set of criteria for something to be
patented which is that it's new it has
to be novel it has to be non-obvious and
it has to be useful and I mean to us
that means it has to be an invention
something that you've invented that
didn't exist before
but the genome is like that the genes no
no piece of DNA is like that it
pre-existed it's not new it is obvious
once you've unraveled it and it's
certainly an achievement to find a gene
and find out what it does but it's not
an invention and invention is the next
thing that you do to actually make a
product a drug or diagnostic test or
whatever and that it seems to us is a
legitimate object of patenting the
actual basic information it seems to us
is not but the the Patent Office is
clearly out to do what it sees as
helping industry as much as it can and
therefore it's set it seems to us anyway
that it's set these rules rather
leniently and as I think John mentioned
earlier there there are challenges being
mounted in various quarters and we may
see the rules being tightened but at the
moment
that they are are pretty pretty generous
you want to add anything I've done
hmm um you say too many problems
concerning like patents and industry and
their involvement in the genetics do you
have any like realistic solutions or
anything that could be done to kind of
alleviate these problems
well I maybe I just take over toward
genius story I I think it must realize
it's not black and white this is a
matter of balance patents have a very
valuable role to play but as Georgina
said they should be down at the invented
level and and in fact the situation in a
sense is is is is almost inevitable that
these power patents are going to be
narrowed it's just that I would like to
see it happening sooner rather than
later and without too many people
getting disadvantaged on the way and
particularly without the rich societies
like our own societies accumulating that
wealth and holding other people back so
I think I think what we're doing and it
is working the the rules are being
tightened is to is to sort of get over
this Klondike Gold Rush phase of biology
and I think the way forward to a great
extent is just talking like we are
tonight so more and more people
understand what's going on more people
say yes I do understand that we we
should be limiting the scope of patterns
to to what truly being achieved by the
by the patent holder and one interesting
there's a dish there's going to be
pressure from other people who want to
invent it's not just a matter of
inventors and the unwashed on the other
hand it's actually inventors competing
with each other because people want in
you know to to enjoy the possibilities
of having further inventions so I think
it will move forward in a democratic way
and I my call is just our call is just
to accelerate that process as much as we
can
I have one question in one comment my
question is I'm as far as club feet go
have they identified the gene for that
any anything like that I haven't heard
that that is that actually I yeah you
exposed an area of ignorance here
because I don't actually know whether
clubfoot is an inherited condition is it
is that clearly known that do you know I
don't know
I had that that genetic problem and it
just so happened that the doctor who
helped me out is a product of Washington
University John McCarroll I think his
son still practices at Children's
Hospital and that's the connection that
I want to know have they identified that
genome I don't know if it's happened yet
but if it does that's great the comment
I want to make is I'm a science teacher
at McClure North High School and
recently Jimmy Carter received the Nobel
Peace Prize and I made sure in my
cultural geography class that that we
were really excited about that we wrote
them letters and now I get to go back
and say I've met or I've talked to a
Nobel Prize winner in medicine and they
are going to be so excited and I am
truly excited that I've had the
opportunity to be here so
congratulations on
hi I'm a physician I have a question
which I believe is extremely important
for the future it seems like from the
technical standpoint a human cloning is
quite possible but is this the right
thing to do because all right
I don't think it is technically quite
possible except with a very great loss
of damaged human beings because remember
that the animal cloning that's taking
place the few animals the very few
animals as the 1% level that survived
the process are in fact themselves
usually slightly damaged Ian's walnuts
spoke with me not very long ago and he
was very good on this pointing out that
there are subtle defects both that the
notes got beyond its biological age
there are defects in the respiratory and
circulatory systems and the it's not
going to produce good human beings at
all the reason why cloning animal
cloning is useful is because by
introducing an additional gene into a
farm animal
and then breeding from that clone you
can in fact produce a useful stable line
and it doesn't involve great cruelty to
the animals certainly I mean it's just
like any other kind of farming practice
it involves obviously manipulating its
life but unless we're vegetarians weird
how causing this to be done every day
and so I think that's that's morally
legitimate but to produce human beings
in the same fashion is certainly not
because you are complicit in killing
very large numbers of human babies
rather painfully because we valued the
human life in a different way and so I
don't think it's technically possible at
the moment should it be so in the future
then I don't you know if I talked quite
a lot about this so I think we both feel
that it's it's not a very sensible thing
to do that it's you know anybody who
wants to clone themselves frankly I I
just don't agree with that you know I
think they should be wanting to bring
somebody different from oneself into the
world I suddenly do who would want to
clone at me home and say but the thing
is but above that is is obviously there
are
small proportion of people who are
desperate for children he you know
through fertility reasons so maybe at
some time in the future when it's
technically possible without producing
offer damaged babies then I might feel a
bit libertarian about it but I think
it's a very big if we've got to get to
the point of that technical true
feasibility at the human level first one
thing I could add is that the discussion
about cloning has has taken two branches
there's reproductive cloning which is
what y'all was talking about which is
using cloning to make new individuals
and then there's what is generally
termed therapeutic cloning which means
starting off a human embryo but only
letting it grow to it to a very limited
stage just a few cells so that you can
extract from that these things called
stem cells which have the potential to
make any cell in the body and there is
active field of research going on at the
moment this kind of work by the way is
and now allowed in the UK the
legislation was passed just recently to
say that it would be permitted and and
the research path and again this is very
very early days is looking for ways to
take those stem cells which have the
potential to become anything and learn
how to direct their differentiation so
that if you need liver cells you could
make liver cells if you need brain cells
you can make brain cells and the hope is
that this might be able to be used to
treat a variety of degenerative human
diseases I I don't have a problem with
that because I don't see I don't have a
problem with dealing with something that
is you know it's so early in development
that it is just a bundle of cells but
clearly people whose beliefs make them
feel that life begins as soon as an
embryo is fertilized would regard even
that degree of cloning as beyond the
pale I have a question in a comment
first of all it was extremely
interesting speech night thanks for
being here I too feel like a gentleman
over there very fortunate to have been
here to listen but my question is
regarding the people who have the
resources to do the development how do
we balance the limitation on the patent
rights which I agree with and in the and
the spreading out of the information to
as many as possible so that the most
amount of research can be done but how
do we balance that between the people
who expend vast resources and amounts of
money to do the research and then limit
their ability to reap the benefits later
on down the road through the invention
of different medicines and treatments I
mean there seems to be a question there
about you know I'm going to go and spend
all this money do the research but then
somehow be limited in my return for the
investment that I'm putting in but well
I mean there are two ways of doing
research you can do it for the public
good or you can do it for private
profits and both illegitimate in their
own areas I think the danger I see this
has been a very substantial drift both
in in this country in my own country
Europe generally so in a great drift
towards the feeling that somehow almost
everything should be done for profit and
I think that's simply a mistake I mean I
gave one or two examples of that think
about the neglected diseases think about
those neglected diseases just as a
concrete example if we merely go for
profit you know the balance sheet the
way you run a publicly quoted company
insists to you that you must go for the
antidepressant market or the you know
the peptic ulcer market or something
where you're going to have as they say a
blockbuster drug which is in their
competing at other blockbuster drugs
it's got to be sold to every individual
or by it it's got to be put on every
pharmacy show whereas the actually not
such vast amounts of money that are
going to be needed
to get a drug to cure TB and cure
malaria and so forth it's very
interesting actually
those companies estimate that bringing a
new drug to market cost between 500 even
800 million dollars only that that cost
is due to a variety of reasons far
beyond the Rd as I showed on my budget
slide and it also incur a great cost in
testing because since these drugs are
not a very only marginally increased
value over previous drugs we rightly
insist that they go through very
elaborate trials now the estimate by
people like the TB Alliance for example
who are poor who are spearheading the
public domain that's to say money
collected from governments and charities
to actually solve TB they're talking
about fifty to a hundred million dollars
probably to bring a drug to market and
that's because they haven't got this is
for-profit
sort of panoply around them now is he
what I mean I think I think what's
happening is the big pharmaceuticals are
being driven to a certain style of
business which is okay but it's not
going to solve most of the problems and
I think we really need to have a bit
more public domain activity there and we
also need to remember that there are
things which are in common there are
things that are pre competitive as they
say in industry which RIT like the human
genome which really are not appropriate
to be to be done in the marketplace now
America actually has the most marvelous
public research through National
Institutes of Health in particular but
through many other agencies and
charities it's actually wonderful the
amount of public domain research is
going on this was the bulk of the Human
Genome Research into the public domain
it worked it's making it available and
actually it's saving money for
researchers in America industrial
researchers every day that that
information is publicly available so
it's a matter of horses for courses you
see you do things for profits when
you're in a level playing field when
you've got inventors competing with each
other another that's what the patent
systems for that's what the free market
free enterprise is all about it works
wonderfully well making cars for example
this is exactly the way to
go when you're dealing with things that
are common goods in the future of human
medicine then you go the other way and
it's keeping these two streams alive and
well
interacting but neither one completely
swamp in the other that makes our
societies work and if we keep that
balance right there working better in
the future john sulston and Georgina
ferry are co-authors of the common
thread a story of science politics
ethics